[Music]
we live in a world where technology has
advanced so that we can collect huge
amounts of data the human mind does not
have the ability just to look at tables
and tables of data and just draw some
conclusions so data science is a logical
way of being able to identify the
structures that are inherent in that
data understanding the business problem
doing the analytics and then providing
some sort of a solution my name is Alena
Carvalho and I'm a data scientist at
Chevron data science is an
interdisciplinary approach for
extracting information out of data in
order to make better decisions the team
of data scientists is pretty diverse one
there are people that come from maybe
the more traditional background they
have statistics degree or computer
science degree but then there are people
that come about it from the other way of
having a deep knowledge of the subject
matter math is beautiful because the
relationships and the way that it could
be used to solve problems and all these
different areas I always say that data
science is about more than just data
scientists we're working with people to
help answer their questions give them
information that we can from their data
that involves developing training
materials actually giving the training
and then perhaps working with people
one-on-one to identify what they need to
do to build their skills in that area
one of the things I like to do when I'm
teaching is to take technical concepts
from the class and then tie them to
things that people might be more
familiar with in their everyday lives I
use some examples from garment
construction there is a lot of
engineering and creating a garment you
have a flat pattern and you've got to
think of how to construct it in a
three-dimensional way data science takes
data and tries to find patterns in the
data to answer questions
[Music]
the data comes from a variety of sources
it could be from the incident
investigation and reporting it could be
from reliability databases and
inspection records maintenance records
and then also operating data the kind of
problems that I work with are trying to
affect or to improve process safety and
so that's helping us be more proactive
rather than reactive I am excited about
the future of data science at Chevron is
gaining a lot of momentum I think
there's a lot of data and we're starting
to get to dig into it and try to get
some insights and I'm really excited to
see where it takes us
you